hello my name is Aaron Gilbert doctor a  particle fan that's step one everywhere  by the way in every crack very hard to  wash off we have dedicated our whole  lives to studying the paranormal  now there's sightings all over the city  there are people out there that need our  help  Boltzmann you're a brilliant engineer  Eric no one's better at quantum physics  than you I always do that I'm joining  the club I know New York you're in hello  I'm here about the receptionist job hi  you're hired  let's go let's go oh did you want to  race I'll let you Li do someone is  creating a device that amplifies  paranormal activity we need to feel  something to fight they stand ghosts  okay I don't know if it was a race thing  or a lady thing but I'm mad as hell I  asked Kevin to throw together couple of  logos for us mmm oh you do see how this  might make us look bad is it the boobs  you don't like cuz I can I can bigger